your attention back to this line which
you should have just after you
integrated
and when you've got in your working and
i think
at this point what we were trying to do
was evaluate the constant
because this is you know we were given
this right we sort of already knew what
the constant was going to be but we
can't just pull it out of nowhere we
have to say
why is it equal to that okay now in
order to work out the constant we had to
put in some value
for x right because this thing has no
x's in it right we're just using this
one plus x to the n because it's
convenient for us we know a lot about it
and it's binomial expansion
and we chose x equals one right why did
we choose x equals one do you remember
um if i remember right we chose x equals
one
right because we saw that in what we're
required to prove
there's a two up here right see that two
and that's kind of like an important
number because it connects to
let's see here um this number over here
right so i can slide it in there that'll
become one plus one to the n plus one
and that's where you get that okay so we
thought okay that's a good way to go
but if you start to put some more lines
in after this you
rapidly find out that it's not taking
you very far okay
and this is what's unusual um between
binomial expansions and what we're used
to with integration
okay normally when you get a constant
integration out if you have a value any
value okay like initial conditions
or you know after t equals five or
whatever if you pop it in
you'll get the constant output okay you
can have any set of values
but here you have to choose a value
which works
in this case one doesn't right now the
question to
to you is well what else can we choose
remember though i'm after is c
right so it's in my interest to get rid
of as much of this other junk that i can
in order to simplify it out so what else
could x equal to
any suggestions yeah
okay x equals negative one okay
now i'll come back to this in a second
there is actually basically three main
options that have come up over and over
again
they're one minus one or what i'm going
to show you in a second
x equals zero now let's just look for a
minute for y x minus one
might be a better option than one okay
what advantages minus one have when we
sub it in
have a look at what you've got here in
particular this term
over here right you put x equals minus
one in
what happens well instead of becoming
like a 2 to the n plus 1 something which
requires an expansion
x equals minus 1 makes this term vanish
right disappears because it's going to
be 1 minus 1 to
some power 0 to some power so it goes
away
okay then you have to deal with this guy
over here on the right hand side now
this will be equal to something
different
now what i'm going to go after is did it
work out for you
got somewhere probably better than one
because like i said that left hand turn
disappears
i think the best option in this case is
x equals zero now after you practice a
few of these you'll start to get a sense
for
which one you'll pick i think you'll see
why in a second
based on what we've got here zero works
best okay so i'm going to say
to evaluate c
let x equal zero okay now that's the
only purpose
i have to evaluate c once i've gotten a
value for c
i'll come back to this line and just
like we did before i'll put in x equals
one
because that gives me the actual
identity that i'm after okay but just
while i'm trying to work out what this
constant is
i'm gonna go with this value okay so
what happens on both sides
i'm gonna get uh one plus zero
m plus one there's my constant
okay now over here what happens well
you've got the sum
of a whole bunch of terms but what other
terms equal to this is the
clue that i was trying to give you
yesterday which obviously wasn't that
good clue
when x equals to zero right um all of
these terms will vanish because
zero to the power of well i don't care
what it's to the power of actually it's
just zero
so therefore everything over here
disappears
even though it's a sum of a whole bunch
of terms um
n plus one terms okay every single term
in this series is zero
right it's this time zero and then the
next one times zero and so on okay
so this right hand side is 0. what do i
have over here on the left
this is 1 to the power of something
right and that's always just
1. okay
do that so therefore now i get my
constant
and i can bring that back into this line
up here okay and since this is
n plus one same denominator okay i can
say therefore
one plus x to the n minus
one on n plus one i've just brought them
together as
part of the same fraction okay that's
equal to the sum of
zero to m and choose r
x to the r plus one r plus one
so now that i've gotten rid of my
constant now it's actually a helpful
time to say
well for this case let's let x equal one
okay
so let x equal one therefore
one plus one to the n minus one
sorry i'm missing a plus one yeah thank
you
um one m plus one
and choose ah that's one
okay so now that i've written that for
full out
i can basically go to this line that's
that's it that's my two
i keep forgetting to write it sorry
minus one and then plus one
and because this numerator is just one
i'll put that entries on the top
and i'm done
right so what do you get out of this
when you're trying to when you have any
identities that require some integration
and you're going to get a constant out
in order to evaluate that you have to be
careful with what value you'd actually
choose
and in this case you've got to choose
one and then you've got to choose
another
okay in order to get the actual identity
at the end
but there's one more thing i want to
draw your attention to
okay because this sort of long way of
doing things
just choosing x equals 0 and then
choosing one right it's a way to
evaluate the constant
right why do we have a constant where
where did it come from
it came from not just integration but
the fact that this is a particular kind
of integral
namely indefinite that's why there's a
constant flying around because i don't
know
what the primitive function will be okay
but
there's a kind of integration which
avoids the problem of a constant
altogether
right namely a definite integral yeah
and the thing is we're bringing
integration in here not because the
question is like find the area blah blah
it's because we can connect what we know
this binomial identity
to an identity that i want to prove
right so
i integrated with respect to x because i
wanted to in the same way i can
integrate over a certain domain
because it's convenient to me okay
so instead of integrating and having an
indefinite integral and then leading to
this problem of a constant okay
i'm going to choose this um these upper
and lower bounds okay not to one so on
both sides i'm going to get this
okay
now why do i choose not and one
for similar reasons as why i chose
naught and then one
here okay so it's going to take a bit of
practice to work out well sometimes it's
going to be minus one to naught
or zero to something else but you'll see
what happens when you've integrated out
okay
i know already what the integrals are
all going to be equal to right but it's
a definite integral so i'm going to go
um 1 plus x to the n line m
plus sorry plus 1. and i'm going to
evaluate from that from not to one
okay and on the right hand side i have
the summation
and choose r and then this i'm also
going to evaluate
from naught to one okay now watch this
remember
all this means is evaluate for one and
then subtract it
when you evaluate it for zero right so
what i'm going to get is this
one plus one plus one
subtract one plus zero
okay so that's just if i want to
evaluate for zero
what happens on the right hand side
evaluate for one so that's this
and then subtract evaluate for zero
okay can you see what's happening here
i've got that
two to the n plus one that i was after
and what's this going to be this is just
going to be
minus 1 right
and of course they have the same
denominator already and then over here
on the right hand side
this is going to be 1 minus 0 which is
just 1
that's my numerator so since the
numerator is just 1 i'll stick the
entries out at the top
and r plus 1 it's this common
denominator okay
so which do you think is a better way to
do it
um and i think it's really amazing um i
think it's a really elegant sort of
solution to a very awkward looking
problem
it's just one two three four lines i
admit they look kind of terrible
this is um starting to get a taste of
sort of university level maths where
it's like
look there's a number there's like only
a few numbers here everything else is
like greek and
widow letters that kind of thing but can
you see how it's a much
more efficient way of really solving the
same kind of problem
okay so sometimes a definite integral
where you have to choose your boundaries
carefully
is really super helpful okay